how do you create the perfect youtube
schedule so I got a question from one of
my master my members this morning for
tgim and she's creating her YouTube
channel and she's going on this 10-day
challenge you ok Haiti Hayden's home
from camp no cam today flag you're
flying okay thank you sir okay so she's
doing uh 10 videos over two weeks I
think it's 55 videos over the five
weekdays and you know different theme
for Monday different theme for tuesday
wednesday thursday friday and so on to
try for two weeks and she's scared and
nervous she's perfectionist and she
wants to get it perfect wanting to be
amazing people to subscribe to her
channel so i have a couple ideas for you
on how to create a schedule that works
for you and your audience the first one
is the days of the week don't really
matter and i just came back from
YouTube's offices their headquarters in
San Francisco and was meeting with him
there and they say the days actually
don't really matter they recommend
people posting different themes of
different days but it's really more just
to try to get content out where people
don't remember that you are posting a
book video on Tuesday right people don't
remember that my my book process video
comes out on a Saturday people don't
remember that my believe life series
comes out in the Sunday they don't
remember and so don't count on people to
remember and come back on Friday because
this theme and wednesday because it's
this seam and I'm going to ignore
Tuesday and Thursday because it's things
that I don't like people won't remember
people subscribe to too many channels
that they won't remember your schedule
the key is that every video is valuable
enough to your audience that they're
going to at least check it out and they
won't unsubscribe so in every video that
you're coming out whatever your schedule
is even if you're covering different
topics you want to think about your core
audience and make sure that you're still
delivering a message that they would be
interested in because otherwise if
there's too much unrelated stuff people
are going to unsubscribe the second
thing is just start right don't worry
about having the perfect schedule I know
that's hard for someone who's a warrior
and is a perfectionist and like and
likes to get you know scared and nervous
and doesn't want to let people down
I'm the same way understand that your
schedule won't be perfect but this is
one iteration of many iterations to come
and I think about my series you look at
the end special series as an example
when I started that it was very selfish
it was I wanted something for me in the
morning to be able to watch to be able
to stretch myself to think bigger it
started from me wanting to get better
and we created this series but I didn't
have a name for it it wasn't called and
stress at the time there was no intro
music there was no theme to it there was
no shot the vents presso at the end uh
you know I wasn't outside I wasn't doing
things that were fun and silly like I do
now and so it's developed over a matter
of months and you can go back and watch
the first one in the series compared to
what i'm doing now it's gotten a lot
better and as a result i'm having more
fun with it and people love it more but
it wasn't perfect at the start right and
so all your series they're gonna I'm not
gonna say gonna suck at the start but
they will get better as you do more and
more and more and more and more and so
don't worry about it being the perfect
version of it now because even now I
look at my videos now look at them now
look at what I do with my videos
typically as a thumbnail right at the
bottom left you'll see the plane and
you'll see a thumbnail just for the
series now pretty much all of the videos
have a thumbnail but as of like two
weeks ago they didn't I'm moving towards
having every video have a theme intro on
it too so the ents presso has a themed
intro there's music there's me kind of
waking up and working out and then
drinking coffee I want all the videos to
have some kind of themed intro but it's
not ready yet we're working on it right
it's a work in progress and so it keeps
getting better and better and better and
better and better so as you do more of
them you will just naturally find new
ideas and better ways to improve each of
these they are making and the last one
is my last slide is to go with the flow
and understand that the schedule is
going to change like this is an
experiment it won't be perfect you may
find and you will find as you go with
this you have your five different series
you'll probably love two of them one of
them you're not going to really enjoy
much and two of them will just be okay
and that's you know that's part of the
business right that's part of
experimenting
understand yourself and what kind of
content that you like to make and that's
natural and then if you're finding
videos that you're not really that
excited about doing that don't get you
you know fire it up when your audience
doesn't care about it you may just drop
those I've dropped lots of series from
my channel and added other ones in that
I felt more excited about and so go with
that flow like don't find yourself
forcing yourself to have to do videos on
a topic just because you set a schedule
for it don't don't have to write a book
video because that's what you're
supposed to do on Tuesdays right that's
that's your limiting belief right that
you've created this schedule so you can
change it whenever you want and so it
highly encourage you to go with the flow
and you'll find that from these some of
them you'll love some of them you won't
love as much and have the courage to
switch gears and take out some of the
videos to then insert something else
that you are passionate about making so
those are my quick thoughts I would love
to know from you guys watching what your
schedule looks like and how often you've
changed it leave in the comments below
thank you guys for watching keen to
believe and I'll see you soon